[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau rendez vous de dimanche en
politique une semaine après l'attentât
de trèbes près de carcassonne et le
geste héroïque du colonel arnaud
beltrame
nous allons nous demander si un nouveau
terrorisme menace les zones rurales et
périurbaines avec nous trois invités le
député la république en marche saône et
loire a fait le gauvin bonjour bonjour
vous êtes membre de la commission des
lois vous avez été rapporteur de la loi
à sylt et vous allez nous dire si
l'arsenal juridique doit évoluer
mahfoud aomar bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le président des maires de l'yonne maire
vous même de valve rabillon c'est le
sentiment de ses élus les leur vie
quotidienne dont vous pourrez témoigner
et puis frédéric paillard bonjour
bonjour vous êtes secrétaire régional
bourgogne franche comté du syndicat de
policiers alliance y en avait on a envie
de vous demander tout de suite votre
sentiment forcément sur le lieutenant
colonel de gendarmerie arnaud beltrame
qui s'est sacrifié comment s'est
ressenti dans les rangs des forces de
l'ordre
c'est un héros il a fait son travail
d'autres auraient fait comme lui il a
fait son travail d'autres auraient fait
comme lui ça a mené à une grande
tristesse dans les rangs et ça ça
conduit nos collègues vraiment prendre
conscience que le risque est partout et
peu
c'est peut se concrétiser à tout moment
en fait cette vigilance s'était un peu
endormie on avait un peu oublié
finalement on oublie vite on va dire que
le fait de la résilience fait qu'au bout
d'un moment
le certains automatismes on va dire se
perdent et peut-être qu'on a un petit un
petit phénomène d'assoupissement qui
malheureusement
ben quand des choses comme ce qui s'est
passé à trèbes arrive à fond quand on se
réveille vraiment brutalement et il faut
vraiment reprendre la marche normale
quoi bafoue d'aomar le lendemain vos
administrés vos collègues maires quel
sentiment domine est la fierté la
tristesse l'idée d'un exemple très élevé
très fort d'abord la voir la tristesse
vraiment une forte tristesse et puis à
un vrai exemple je crois que le colonel
était un vrai exemple mais je dois dire
qu'à titre personnel moi j'ai ressenti
comme comme représentant en fin de
compte l'être humain peut-être ce qu'il
doit faire et est sage c'est encore le
plus beau de tous je pense parfait
legault va comme beaucoup de
parlementaires vous étiez à l'hommage
national
alors vous vous disiez dans cette
émission beaucoup d'émotion on a le
sentiment qu emmanuel macron a voulu
aussi en faire sors de deux premiers
symboles de son quinquennat sur le
terrorisme ouais tout à fait de
d'incarner se bat ce héros comme on a
dit tout à l'heure mais oui à la
cérémonie avait beaucoup d'émotion
également aussi beaucoup de beaucoup de
gravité
je crois que vous l'avez dit on prend
conscience que évident notre pays est en
guerre et que c'est pas la sphère de
quelques mois ou de même de quelques
semaines ou quelques mois ça ça va être
la sphère d'une ou plusieurs générations
guerre qui se poursuit et vous vous
n'aviez pas en tant que parlementaire et
est directement confronté à ce
terrorisme encore directement est tout à
fait moi je vais travailler donc sur la
loi sur l oit sylt qui nous a permis de
sortir de l'état d'urgence mais tout en
préservant avec en mettant en place un
certain nombre d'outils à la disposition
de la police et de la gendarmerie pour
combattre le terrorisme
mais c'est vrai qu'on n'avait pas eu un
attentat majeur sous 7
législature mais on le sait tous un
c'est une guerre sur plusieurs
générations et le risque zéro n'existe
pas donc il faut être extrêmement
vigilant enfin on va peut-être venir
rassurer on va la réponse et juridique
n'est pas que juridique
justement à propos d'une réponse qui
n'est pas que juridique frédéric
paillard plus techniquement l'arrivée
rapide des gendarmes à trèbes
l'engagement immédiat du colonel
beltrame
ça correspond aussi à un changement de
doctrine en france par rapport à ce type
d'acte avant on va dire pour faire
simple on arrivait on sécurise et ont
encerclé envoyait aujourd'hui on
intervient tout de suite très
directement on intervient tout de suite
très directement puisqu'il ya eu 1 re
dimensionnement des forces qui s'est
fait on a des antennes des services
spécialisés qui près du gipn qui sont
régionaliser donc qui interviennent très
rapidement et dans la doctrine
normalement dans les vingt minutes qui
suivent le début de la commission des
fêtes et au rich man on est en mesure
d'intervenir est de neutraliser
l'individu est ce que le bataclan aurait
été différent avec cette doctrine de
bataclan je pense qu'on peut pas le
prendre en point de référence puisqu'on
est sur une zone très très urbaine qui
est la capitale et on avait ces services
la proximité donc le bataclan on ne peut
pas le prendre en ça a été un changement
très profond pour les services de
sécurité ce changement de doctrine et il
a fallu le temps de toute façon qu'on
s'adapte et qu'on s'approprie les outils
qui sont mis à notre disposition
puisqu'il ya eu des gros effort de fait
pour doter nos collègues des psig sabre
pour la partie gendarmerie et des
brigades anti criminalité pour la police
des outils des matériels et des moyens
nécessaires à la neutralisation
d'individus dans ce qu'elle veut dire
d'avoir aidé du langage que peu
administratif des armes d'impact
beaucoup plus fort des outils de
protection de l'informatique c'est quoi
concrètement ça veut dire que quand les
gens partent là dessus maintenant qu'est
ce qu'ils ont de plus que précédemment
un groupe de gendarmes qui partait aux
policiers comme vous à ce moment là on
va dire qu'ils sont équipés de matériel
de guerre pour faire très très
schématique et notamment moi je les ai
vus notamment je suis allé voir il ya
quinze jours à chalon la gendarme est
donc il ya un psy qui sabrent donc est
en capacité de monter si jamais une
tuerie de mars de masse arrive dans les
environs de chalon
en saône et loire est effectivement sont
les gens qui sont sur entraînés concon
du matériel de guerre pour faire face à
ce type de piau curie et qui sont
capables de monter 24 heures sur 24 7
jours sur 7 et d'intervenir voilà je
crois que c'est la doctrine des vingt
minutes c'est ça au moindre signal
ils peuvent être en mesure d'intervenir
et ça je crois que ça il ya eu une prise
de conscience femme je suis a pas eu
il ya une grande continuité de l'état en
par rapport à ça il ya une conscience
des services de l'ensemble des services
de l'état
depuis l'attentât du bataclan et ses
services donc au niveau de la police ou
la gendarmerie avec la mise en place de
ces trois qui est une trentaine de six
arbres en france ça fait parti de cette
évolution de cette et où l'état s'est
véritablement au delà de des lois qui
ont été votées etc
mais l'état s'est équipée et s'est
adapté à cette menace est assez c'est ce
risque qui peut arriver on l'a vu donc
la semaine dernière s'est pas seulement
à paris
voilà on va essayer voilà on va y venir
un mot quand même sur l'émotion on a vu
il y avait beaucoup de gens le long du
cortège pour le colonel beltrame en même
temps j'ai envie de vous dire après
charlie hebdo comme l'a dit un chanteur
les gens embrasser les flics et puis
c'est passé
le fou d'emma votre point de vue ce qui
se passe est différent ce personnage
créé quelque chose vous ça va passer
aussi non je crois pas que ça va passer
mais vous savez je on a de plus que de
plus qu'on vise depuis qu'on vit ces
événements là on a puisé de plus en plus
du top tendance on a la certitude que
les forces de l'ordre se sont vraiment
c'est notre liberté en réalité ce qui
n'était pas prévu précédemment c'était
c'était parce qu'on pensait précédemment
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on pense moi qui
ai affaires et aux gendarmes et aux
policiers régulièrement dans le cadre de
mes fonctions d'élu je me rends compte
qu'ils sont vraiment investis et qu'ils
sont près de la population ils sont pour
la population et ça il ya quand même un
vrai changement dans le besoin de ça
mais en même temps c'est vous savez que
l'affection de la population elle a
passé la dernière fois c'est vrai ça
fait plaisir à entendre c'est vrai mais
par contre ce qu'il faut quand même
rappeler ben c'est que dans nos rangs il
ya de la tristesse il ya de l'émotion
depuis
le début de la vague d'attentats en 2015
on a quand même neuf membres des forces
de l'ordre qui sont tombées et on a
quatre policiers qui ont été tués en
mission sur sur ce type de sur ce type
d'attentât donc c'est quand même quelque
chose qui est quand même assez prégnant
chez nous et qui représente vraiment le
la mission régalienne du policier ses
protégés c'est pas fort juillet c'est
pas vraiment voilà on tourne pas dans le
système ou n'est là pour verbaliser on
est là pour faire tout un tas de choses
que c'est vraiment appelle l'attention
c'est vraiment le coeur de métier de la
police
alors il ya eu une émotion et puis à la
réaction comme toujours avec chez
laurent wauquiez marine le pen très vite
l'exigence de mesures sécuritaires
encore plus forte rafale gauvin est ce
que c'est pas le moment après un
attentat de rétablir l'état d'urgence on
a eu l'état d'urgence en réponse à
certains attentats il n'y a plus d'état
d'urgence qu'est-ce qu'il faut leur
mettre bas là on a eu alors le débat
revient mais on a eu ce débat donc en
certes en septembre dernier un de savoir
si oui ou non il fallait sortir d'état
d'urgence je crois que ce qu'il faut
qu'on écoute et s'était d'ailleurs notre
démarche quand on a mis en place vous ai
dit ainsi quatre outils à la disposition
des policiers et des gendarmes pour
lutter contre le terrorisme
je pense que les premières personnes
qu'il faut qu'on écoute c'est les
services de police et de gendarmerie
c'est les hommes qui sont au front qui
sont sur le terrain et tous vous dise
moi je prendrais un ancien grand flic
qui est dans les rangs de l air monsieur
péchenard tous je vous dise ça ne sert à
rien de rétablie aujourd'hui l'état
d'urgence on va être exploité les
spectacles question est là un certain
nombre de points de l'état d'urgence ont
été intégrés dans la loi la loi quand
vous êtes occupés en quelques mots le
point juridique c'est quoi l'état
d'urgence c'est fait pour réagir de
manière temporaire à une situation
exceptionnelle
là c'est ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure on est en guerre et on sait que
ça va pas durer c'est pas la sphère de
quelques semaines ou de quelques mois ou
deux et donc ce qu'il faut c'est adapter
notre droit commun et c'est ce qu'on a
fait c'est ce qu'on a fait et donc c'est
adapter notre droit commun tout en
préservant les libertés publiques et
tout le débat qu'on a eu en septembre
selon débat avec les services de police
avec les juristes etc c'était de
préserver cet équilibre là et
aujourd'hui la loi est en application
moi je suis aussi chargé de surveiller
son application et donc tous les jours
on a les différents chiffres qui nous
remontent etc
on voit comment elle est appliquée sur
le terrain s'il faut l'adapter
perfectionner certains outils peut-être
même créer de nouveaux outils je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas on est à l'écouté
permanente et on pourra faire évoluer
mais en tout cas réagir à voir ce
concours lépine de la deûle affichait
sous 2 il se passe quelque chose il faut
qu'on fasse une loi
je crois que ça ça sert à rien c'est on
donne un coup de menton mais ça sert à
rien ce qu'il faut c'est être à l'écouté
des encore une fois des gens qui sont au
front par l'emballement terrorisme on
leur demande est faite avec paillarès
que l'état du retour d'état d'urgence
c'est ce que demandent les policiers les
gendarmes ou non et on va être clair sur
le sujet l'état d'urgence tel qu'il
était fait avant et est tel que la loi
était faite s'imposait la loi a été
modifiée
qu'on applique la loi et qu'on vérifie
convoi comme comme l'a dit le
législateur qui est en face de moi qu'on
vérifie la pertinence et que s'il ya
besoin de retoucher la loi qu'on
retouche la loi on n'a pas besoin de se
remettre dans une situation où
en plus on va créer quand même un
malaise on va fatiguer inutilement les
forces de l'ordre puisque sous l'état
d'urgence quand même rappeler qu'on a
quand même on a quand même des
contraintes qui sont autres que celles
du quotidien on va dire en temps normal
donc ça serait quand même un peu inutile
et contre-productif de venir alourdir
notre travail du quotidien qui est déjà
très contraint mahfoud à omar le
ressenti que vous avez vous sur le
terrain avec la population avec les
maires c'est quoi c'est que les gens ils
voudraient qu'on prenne des mesures
encore plus fortes
on disait que vous me parlez de concours
lépine de la fiche s ou est ce que
finalement ils ont le sentiment que qui
sont protégés et que ce qui existe en
est suffisant quand ils ont le sentiment
qu'ils s'en protéger le souci si vous
voulez c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on a ce
style de drame
il ya la peur qui revient un petit peu
dans la tête des gens et au moment où la
peur revient dans la tête des gens il ya
obligatoirement des des objectifs
politiques qui font que la manipulation
politique pour vous dire tout simplement
qu'ils font que eh bien il faut jouer il
faut surfer sur ses peurs parce que
c'est là il faut caresser les genres
dans le sens du poil etc
et je crois qu'il faut pas le faire
parce que ce qui nous unit ce qui nous
unit en france c'est les libertés
ce qui nous unit en france c'est cette
façon de vivre ensemble et si on doit
modifier les choses pour vivre ensemble
pour rendre je dire pour répondre à des
criminels on est dans leurs objectifs et
moi ce que j'entends autour de moi c'est
on va continuer à vivre comme avant
on va continuer à faire les choses comme
avant et c'est pas ces gens là qui vont
nous obliger à être différent de ce que
l'on est
on est français on vit d'une certaine
façon on continuera à vivre de cette
façon là juste pour réagir je crois que
là là le besoin d'unité nationale face
notamment à ce phénomène le terrorisme
je pense qu'il est très important et je
rappellerai que la sortie d'état
d'urgence le vote de la loi sylt il ya
eu une quasi unanimité de l'ensemble des
partis de gouvernement pour voter la
sortie des terres d'urgence et la mise
en place des nouveaux instruments parti
socialiste a voté
même les élèves
alors pas à l'assemblée nationale parce
que peut-être pour des raisons
politiciennes mais en tout cas le sénat
parce qu'il ya eu vous savez ce qu'on
appelle une commission mixte paritaire
on est voilà qui avait réuni d2 et donc
on a eu le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale qui ensemble ont voté la
sortie l'état d'urgence et la mise en
place de saison de ces nouveaux outils
et l'analyse que je vous ai fait tout à
l'heure c'était partagée par la quasi
totalité de la classe politique et qui
avait ce sentiment qu'ils voulaient
mettre leur pays au dessus des intérêts
de leur parti et je pense que dans ce
qu'elle avait pas le cas ces derniers
jours avec moi alors je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous et je pense que
encore une fois il y avait énormément
d'émotion mercredi
mercredi dernier à la cérémonie
et je pense que sur ce terrain là que
l'on ait des débats mais c'est normal
qu'ils aient des oppositions politiques
sur l'économie sur l'école etc
mais je pense que avec les attentes à
cette guerre qu'on doit mener et
notamment vis-à-vis de nos forces de
l'ordre je pense que c'est important que
la classe politique soit uni et au
soutien derrière nos forces y allant lui
nuire et il ya eu une unité qui était un
peu nouvelle à l'assemblée tout le monde
l'a remarqué c'est le choix de jean-luc
mélenchon et la france insoumise bien
sûr de vous suivre sur cette ligne là
sur cette ligne qui est on en rajoute
pas on ne rajoute pas mesure là on doit
comprendre que ce sera à partir de
maintenant on va dire la ligne du du
quinquennat pour emmanuel macron pour
edouard philippe pour le gouvernement
la ligne se tient on ne rajoute pas de
mesures supplémentaires la loi elle est
déjà là et c'est ce que je vous dis chez
eux on peut faire évoluer ces jeux qu'on
a dit c'est à dire que si les ja n'y a
pas de s'il faut faire évoluer notamment
les visites domiciliaires ou s'il ya des
des perquisitions à dévoyer voila voila
comme s'il faut apporter des correctifs
le faire évoluer
on le fera et d'ailleurs si on a mis en
place ce contrôle permanent par les
palabres par les parlementaires de la
doua sylt c'est justement pour répondre
à ça s'il faut faire évoluer on le fera
évoluer mais on va pas retomber dans
l'état d'urgence je crois que ce serait
un recul mais et qui viendraient en plus
ce qui serait totalement comme comme
vous l'avez
10 ce serait totalement contre-productif
notamment vis-à-vis des forces de
l'ordre un petit mot sur vous comme
celle qu'on avait parlé en parlant de
concours lépine de la fiche s mais on
entend parler de ça tout le temps
personne n'y comprend rien je suppose
que ça doit vous vous énervez un petit
peu parce qu'on sait que c'est un outil
la fiche s au départ c'est un outil pour
les services de renseignement est ce
qu'il faudrait juste pas arrêter
d'utiliser ces termes là et ces mots
parce que c'est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça la réalité est tout à fait c'est
un outil qui est mis à disposition durée
du législateur c'est un outil qui est
mis à disposition de la justice et de
nos collègues pour travailler c'est un
outil à géométrie variable bien entendu
puisque c'est fed indicateur s'est fait
de cases
donc c'est quelque chose qui ne devrait
normalement pas souffrir de fantasmes
parce qu on a des fantasmes autour de la
fiche s mais il faut rappeler quand même
qu'on peut être fichés est ce parce
qu'on était hooligans dans un club de
foot ultra dans un club de foot ou des
choses comme ça la fichait c'est une
fiche qui traite de tout ce qui peut
être atteinte à la sûreté de l'état donc
les atteintes à la sûreté de l'état
il n'ya pas malheureusement que le
terrorisme qui atteint à la sûreté de
l'état
alors on en on en avait peu parlé lors
de la tempête saint-etienne du rouvray
parce qu'il y avait une dimension
symbolique avec un prêtre et une église
mais avec l'attentât très bon nez dans
un terrorisme un peu nouveau certains
qualifient d' artisanale en tout cas
dans des zones jusque là épargnée par ce
que est ce que ce terrorisme dans ce que
vous vous entendez dents à l'assemblée
raphaël gauvin est ce qu'ils se
déplacent vers des zones rurales parce
que les grandes villes sont sécurisés
est ce que c'est une stratégie nouvelle
est ce qu'on sait quelque chose là
dessus
non mais j'en doute enfin les gens qui
qui commettent ces attentats ce
disque-là les zones rurales où les
petites villes villes moyennes ne sont
pas mais encore une fois ça c'est
quelque chose qui est anticipée qui a
été anticipé par par les services de
l'état on parlait tout à l'heure des
psig des psig sabres et de deux on a
formé beaucoup plus de gens capables de
réagir et de stopper une tuerie de masse
que ça se passe en territoire rural ou
dans les villes moyennes
donc en tout cas l'état à sa disposition
s'est adapté pour parer à s'envoler
on découvre pas maintenant ce risque là
dans ces zones là non non ça je pense
que va en tout cas ça a été anticipé
vous l'avez dit on est sur du terrorisme
d'un peu d'opportunités donc là on a
quelque chose qui a démarré aux abords
d'une caserne de crs puisque je rappelle
quand même dans un collecteur et c'est
le point de départ carcassonne et
ensuite forcément dans l'état d'avancée
des choses c'est un petit peu comme le
stade de france le stade de france il ya
une partie qui a commencé à proximité du
stade de france qui a évolué dans la rue
saint-jacques avec a évolué dans saint
denis
ensuite on a également le bataclan il y
en a une partie qui s'est faite sur le
site proprement dit du bataclan et après
ça a évolué dans le xième donc on a en
fait une adaptation en fonction de la
situation à partir du moment où on va
dire qu'à partir du moment où la grenade
à pau multiples puisque c'est un petit
peu ça est dégoupillée
et puis qu'elle éclate elle peut éclater
à différents endroits
mafuta omar est ce que en tant que maire
d'une petite commune
est ce que ça vous inquiète est ce que
ça vous inquiète surtout sur les
conséquences que cela peut avoir sur la
vie vos communes
ce déplacement lors pas forcément dans
la réalité mais en tout cas dans
l'esprit et dans la mentalité des gens
alors ce risque terroriste déjà il faut
savoir que dans les petites communes
déjà depuis plusieurs années on est on
est sensibilisé
on a des réunions on a eu des réunions
avec la préfecture avec les services de
police avec des services de gendarmerie
est on est on est préparé déjà c'est à
dire depuis plusieurs années on sait que
ça peut arriver donc les les maires des
communes des communes rurales ne sont
pas ça use c'est pas quelque chose qui
découvrent c était au début une crainte
on s'est dit mais pour cours nous disent
à quoi dans mon petit village qu'est ce
qui va c'est parce que ça s'est passé ça
on vous a dit va falloir que vous soyez
vigilants c'est ça et on s'est dans un
premier temps on s'est dit mon petit
village comment et puis peu à peu avec
les discussions avec la préfecture et
les services de la préfecture avec avec
la gendarmerie
on a pris cette conscience et
aujourd'hui on a vraiment cette
conscience notre objectif c'est quoi
c'est cette continuer à vivre comme
avant par contre de faire attention
vous savez
dans un dans une grande surface dans un
aéroport un sac qui est laissée dans un
coin on fait beaucoup plus attention
aujourd'hui qui a 20 ans il ya vingt ans
regarder pas du tout aujourd'hui on
regarde bien quelque chose d'un peu
bizarre dans un village on regardera on
s'intéressera on voit bien la dimension
positive de jeu il se passe quelque
chose j'alerte la gendarmerie ge
mais ce qui a pas en creux le risque de
bain je me trompe et ça aura des
conséquences sur la vie quotidienne de
notre petite commune et les gens seront
que le maire est allé parler à la
gendarmerie et et toutes ces choses là
ça c'est parce que finalement c'est un
espèce défaite déflagration du
terrorisme sur notre vie quotidienne
oui c'est vrai mais je crois qu'on se
pose pas ce style de questions se dit
pas si je me trompe
évidemment il faut qu'il y ait des
éléments qui soit vraiment probant on a
l'habitude dans nos villages puis vous
savez faut pas oublier aussi que dans un
village des choses se voient beaucoup
plus facilement que dans une grosse
commune que dans une ville donc des
petits détails ce tout de suite savio
après il faut faire le tri évidemment
faut faire le tri mais je crois qu'il
faut rien négliger
il faut rien négliger parce que pour
continuer à vivre comme on le fait il
faut rien négliger
voilà il faut être cette idée quand même
dans les rapports qu'on a dans le monde
rural que le voisin d'à côté puisse
devenir une menace c'est assez différent
de la ville finalement vous êtes très
attaché je le sais vous l'avait dit en
début d'émission à cette idée du vivre
ensemble suppose que c'est le travail du
maire de réussir à garder tout le monde
oui et puis la plupart des gens du temps
quand les gens c'est quand les gens se
connaissent ils ne se posent pas c'est
vrai qu'ils se posent pas la question si
si le mal va venir d'une personne qui
connaisse moi c'est plutôt quand il ya
quelque chose qui qu'il ne qui ne
connaissent pas un indice qui arrivait
qu'ils ne connaissent pas mais on on vit
très bien en campagne et on n'a pas peur
on continuera à vivre très bien tout cas
après l'attentât de trèbes n'ya pas
encore chez vous dans vos villages de
sentiment que ça va venir dans les zones
rurales non il ya cette crainte toujours
cette crainte qui existe mais je crois
en fait que cette petite crainte on doit
s'y habituer et elle doit persister
parce que c'est ce qui nous permet
d'être en éveil sur beaucoup de choses
voyez dans beaucoup de pays les gens
vivent normalement ils font attention
donc c'est on peut vivre avec ça il ya
aucun souci je crois juste nommé pour
rebondir par rapport à ça
les les gendarmes aussi en milieu
rural font un travail de renseignement
qui extrêmement notamment depuis les
attentats y est pour prévenir ce type il
faut un travail de renseignement en
amont enfin moi je suis allé voir à buxy
givry
ils sont véritablement au contact de la
population il se déplaçant et dès qu'ils
ont leur donne la moindre information
ils vont la vérifier que ce temps donc
il ya aussi ce travail de prévention
d'aller chercher du renseignement qui
est très important et en zone rurale la
gendarmerie en fin d'après ce que j'ai
pu comprendre fait véritablement ce
travail de terrain
ben pour prévenir ce type d'acte ya la
gendarmerie et est ce que les services
de renseignements de façon générale ils
sont adaptés à cette éventualité que le
risque terroriste se déplace sur le
territoire on avait beaucoup dit que
lors de la réforme sur le renseignement
intérieur les renseignements généraux
avait été largement réduits on sait
qu'il ya pas mal de recrutement qui se
sont faits pour ré augmenter le nombre
de fonctionnaires est ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui capable de mailler le
territoire suffisamment mais de toute
façon le territoire il est maillé
puisque dans les rangs dans les rendus
du renseignement on a des gendarmes qui
sont dédiés on a des policiers et on a
un service de renseignement qui a été on
va dire augmenter en personnel depuis
depuis les attentats de 2015
concrètement ça signifie quoi par
exemple vous vous êtes responsable pour
bourgogne franche comté on a une idée de
ce que ça représente
ça représente en fait on a eu
on a 1500 on a eu 1500 collègues en plus
sur tout le territoire national qui ont
été affectés aux renseignements donc on
a quelque chose qui est vraiment qui est
vraiment palpable
on a des services qui ont été renforcées
on va prendre des petits postes qui
existe dans des petites localités où on
est passé à dix fonctionnaires alors
qu'à l'origine une était à 2 donc on a
vraiment un système qui s'est adaptée et
la culture du renseignement ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que la culture du renseignement en
france a changé les changes des
informations est important et on pense
logiquement et alliance police nationale
pense logiquement qu'il faut encore
évoluer plus et qu'on est vraiment
qu'une seule centrale de renseignements
qu'on ait qu'un front commun qu'ils
puissent ce qu'ils veulent qu'ap
opérationnelle non on a on a différents
en différents services et on a
différents
différents niveaux d'intervention des
équipes aux législateurs rapporteur de
la loi l'entente là c'est plus de
l'organisation d'etats médiation mais
enfin ce que vous dites est très très
variés enfin il ya des moyens
supplémentaires qui sont mieux depuis le
le bataclan puis à l'autre parent du
renseignement à la qui est en devenir
il ya un gros effort qui fait c'est le
renseignement pénitentiaire où là il ya
une montée en puissance ça les gens
l'ignorent ça signifie qu'à l'intérieur
des prisons il ya des gens dont le
métier cette collecter de l'informatique
exactement exactement de quoi c est de
les surveiller
c'est que surveillant sais quoi parce
que on se demande alors ce sont des gens
de l'administration pénitentiaire mais
qui sont dédiés à sa qui ne qui ne font
que ça et que on va pas décrire
exactement justement et puis disent pas
tout parce que ça doit rester secret
mais l'objectif c'est une chose dans les
prisons terre qu'est ce qu'on doit
comprendre en creux c'est ça que ça veut
dire qu'il ya des choses qui partent des
prisons carrément essais on sait que
c'est un foyer du 2-2 radicalisation et
qu' il ya beaucoup de la plupart des
terroristes sont passés par la case
prison
et aussi il ya beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont été condamné dans les années
2010-2011 qui sont là bientôt en fin de
peine qui vont ressortir et donc c'est
essentiel que dans les prisons bayer ce
travail de renseignements pour pouvoir
à leur sortie les suivre ou mettre en
place des mesures type celle qu'on a
voté les ce qu'on appelle les me casse
où on met en place des mesures
individuelles pour avec une contrainte
toujours dans le respect des libertés
mais à une certaine contrainte parce que
il présente un risque potentiel et donc
c'est essentiel qu'on puisse dans la
prison avoir services de renseignement
et d'évaluation de leurs dangereux séché
obligé de vous couper cette afin de
l'isoler
non pas du tout beaucoup c'était la fin
de notre débat on aurait pu continuer on
espère en tout cas ne pas avoir à
l'aborder trop souvent merci à tous les
trois d'être venus débattre
restez avec nous sur france 3 pour la
deuxième partie de dimanche en politique
francis
letellier reçoit florian philippot bon
dimanche au revoir